winter is coming and if it's moving at 2
miles per hour in a generally southward
direction in the Seven Kingdoms are
about 3500 miles long then it'll take
about 1750 hours to get here
dang that's a lot of episodes
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that promises to get its own
HBO subscription any day now any day now
I mean it would be kind of nice to watch
new episodes of Game of Thrones and
their Full HD quality and not in that
360p of other less savory websites but
with new episodes are leaking every
other day HBO what do you expect me to
do wait a full week I got a binge okay
so this is the part where I usually do a
little segue catching you up on where
the show is but whether or not you like
it you are caught up with Game of
Thrones because Twitter is dark and full
of spoilers but even if you've been
avoiding Twitter because it's filled
with more angry mobs than King's Landing
being caught up with the show doesn't
mean a whole lot these days
in a show where winter took six seasons
to come
season seven has us ricocheting between
a beds and a breakneck pace we're gonna
attack this castle smash cut it's done
I'm going to cure you BAM you're healed
send a raven to the north oh wait never
mind here's Jon Snow and yet there's
still a lot that has to happen before
the end of the series John and Danny
have to fall in love even though they're
totally cousins John stops calling them
the white walkers and the knight King
because it's the worst branding ever and
finally calls them but we'll finally get
everyone's attention ice freakin zombies
then people finally believe him but by
then it's too late george RR martin
gives everyone a big middle finger just
what a happy ending was on the horizon
by killing everyone off with ice zombies
and leaving us with the final message of
we didn't listen then in the final
epilogue the Lord of Light swoops in to
revive Ned Stark or someone who doesn't
look like him and doesn't like him but
that raises the question how will they
fit all that stuff in in reality game of
Thrones as the TV show has a big problem
which is how the heck they're gonna get
everything to happen in the few episodes
that they have left I mean for crying
out loud it takes half the show to say
Daenerys his full title Tara Stormborn
of the House Targaryen first birthday
the unburnt queen of Andals and first
men Khaleesi of the great grass sea
breaker of chains and other dragons so
how long is it gonna take to conquer all
of Westeros and add even more titles for
the stuff that she conquers well raise a
toast to House spoiler and prepare to
spend the night in the Citadel because
we're going in depth to uncover Westeros
is bed
yep secrets that gameofthrones literally
cannot finish in the time that they have
left and that they're cheating their own
canon universe to make it all happen
not that the show needs any more
exposing than it already has
I mean geez leave something to my
imagination Georgie so what am I talking
about here well like I said season seven
is rushing through events fast enough to
give you whiplash and in the process
they're breaking its own universe to
speed up the pace of the show at the
beginning of season seven we find Cersei
and humongous debt to the iron bank
while more and more of her allies leave
her for the younger hotter and slightly
less incestuous gal Daenerys with
Casterly Rock the Lannisters historical
source of income completely mined out
Circe's back is up against the wall so
when she has to pay her debts as
Lannisters tend to do she orders her
army to leave Casterly Rock to take
Highgarden and asks the representative
of the iron bank give me a full night
stay in King's Landing as my oneth guest
and when you return to Braavos I swear
to you my debt will be paid in full so
for one of the first times in the show
were given a ticking clock with a very
specific time frame for when something
needs to happen now usually the show
keeps things nice and vague so they
avoid problems like this and mostly we
just kind of shrug and stop thinking
about it the next time we see some
culled Rogow packs pop into frame or
Daenerys set herself on fire this time
though we got you Georgie according to
Cersei in just a fortnight which in case
you're not up on your English time
measurements is 14 days the Lannister
army has to hoof it from Casterly Rock
to Highgarden then back to King's
Landing you might have some quibbles
about that sentence
don't worry I'll address them but the
first question is how far Casterly Rock
is from Highgarden it's never directly
stated in the show or the books exactly
how far away these places are from one
another but there are official maps so I
gave myself some theorist cartography
lessons and went to work the first thing
I needed to get was a base measurement
and for that I went to the wall which is
basically the only landmark that has a
specific measurement associated with it
george RR martin specifically set the
size of the wall as 300 miles or 482
kilometres in a 2008 interview and Jon
Snow reiterates it in chapter
forty-eight of gameofthrones the book
it's even cited in the Game of Thrones
telltale games 300-mile wall and you'll
still in my way in the show Samwell
Tarly at one point claims that the wall
is five hundred miles across we didn't
build 500 miles of ice walls 700 feet
high to keep out men but we'll be nice
and say that it was just the cold
talking since no one ever corroborates
that and frankly it would make this
show's case even worse it's also before
he goes to maester school so what's he
really know well certainly more than jon
snow
you know newton chinese snow using 300
miles as a baseline we can measure out
raven routes sailing routes and of
course marching routes Casterly Rock and
Highgarden are connected by a winding
road known as the sea road if you're
thinking well that could have marched
straight ahead instead remember that an
army comes with all kinds of equipment
and provisions and moving along the road
is gonna be significantly faster than
marching through woods the road is about
660 miles or 1062 kilometers long so we
now know that the Lannister troops are
gonna have to march 660 miles in just
two weeks which puts them at a breakneck
pace of 47 miles a day or almost twice
the length of a marathon for 14 days in
a row I'll save you the speculating
during the medieval era which is a
fairly close approximation to the world
of Game of Thrones this would have been
impossible
medieval troop movements were mostly
limited by the logistics of beating an
entire army as it moved which meant that
in hostile territory it was hard for a
medieval army to move more than 10 miles
a day because the head of the army had
to forage the whole area around the road
but we'll say for the sake of argument
that the Casterly Rock army is well
provisioned and since they're moving in
friendly territory that they could move
at maximum speed the maximum speed for
an unbounded army tended to be around 20
miles or 32 kilometers a day well that
number does go up to 30 miles a day for
a mounted contingent we know from the
end of the episode the spoils of war
that the majority of Lannister troops
were indeed on foot in the most extreme
of circumstances that I can find for
this period in Roman times troops were
expected to be able to move one
for miles in about five hours though
this was considered full pace with
sparingly used and we never actually see
the Lannister army running except away
from Danny's sweet dragon literally it's
like third degree anyway even if this
impossibly grueling pace for 10 hours a
day they would just barely make it to
Highgarden before Circe's deadline and
that's not even taking into account the
journey back with the gold but don't
worry Internet I've predicted your
rebuttals in advance maybe Cersei was
planning ahead and she had secretly sent
borders to her troops to attack
Highgarden two or three weeks in advance
except she didn't the mornings at the
iron bank comes a-knockin Circe's
bedchamber was a rock in with some sweet
sweet brother lovin I can't even say it
sarcastically it's just gross
I'm the queen kingdoms I'll do as I
please yeah yeah Cersei enjoy it while
it lasts but by betting old Jaime she's
keeping him from getting to Highgarden
and we clearly see him arriving with the
troops don't you hate it when physics
and geography get in the way of you
dating your sibling me neither
the distance from King's Landing to
Highgarden along the rows road is about
840 miles or about 1350 kilometers which
means that to make it from King's
Landing to Highgarden before the attack
Jaime is gonna need to leave the red
keep as soon as he gets out of bed that
morning and start one of the most
intense journeys of his life
Jaime is gonna have to ride a hard 60
miles per day well this wouldn't be
impossible for someone on a race horse
to do for a day or two for 14 days
straight this would definitely kill the
horse and almost definitely kill Jaime
meaning that Jaime would have killed 14
horses between King's Landing and
Highgarden
and he would have arrived in a coma and
he'd still be a few hours late and okay
Jaime I know you're a dedicated knight
and all that but are you break the laws
of physics dedicated because even if you
make it there take over Highgarden that
same day without dying alongside Olenna
you've only just captured the place you
still have to get a raven back to King's
Landing on that same day a raven that
would have to be flying over 800 miles
per hour to make it back the same day in
order to meet Circe's insane 14-day
deadline and that certainly means that
no gold is making it back to the iron
in that amount of time so sorry George
RR Jaime literally being in all parts of
the map all the time in season seven has
busted you on this one even if Cersei
had asked the iron bank representative
to stay there a month everything would
have had to have moved like clockwork
and they would still have barely made it
on time all right so the situation is
looking pretty bleak but here's the
thing guys I love Game of Thrones I
don't want to show that Daenerys is
genetically impossible because of
inbreeding
even though you should totally check out
that episode shameless plug I want to
find a way to make this work and it
turns out I have believe it or not there
actually is a way to make all of this
impossibly fast movement happen in the
show to make it possible to fit
everything that needs to happen into the
final 10 episodes and no it's not to
somehow make Westeros smaller but you're
kind of close it's to make everything in
Westeros bigger what do I mean by that I
mean that the way to make all of this
time hopping fast travel work is to
actually make every person tree and
direwolf in Westeros twice as large as
we think they are I know I know it
sounds far-fetched but stick with me
here if every one is twice as large then
movement speeds are twice as fast and
while time frames like that fortnight
are still really tight it goes from so
far outside the realm of possibility
that even Marvel writers are skeptical
too unlikely but possible and believe it
or not there is actual evidence in the
show that points to this maybe being
true for a few episodes of series but
most notably the pilot exterior shots of
Winterfell used done castle while most
of Game of Thrones remains purposely
vague with its measurements Winterfell
specifically is given some measurements
that suggests some pretty wacky
proportions its outer walls for example
are supposed to be 80 feet tall the
walls at dun castle are 39 feet tall
just half of what Winterfell is supposed
to have if you see people who look like
normal people standing in front of a
39-foot wall but then you're told that
that wall is actually 80 feet you'll
suddenly realize that either the wall is
half the height and you were lied to or
that the people you're looking at are
actually twice as tall as you thought
they were since we don't have any normal
earth sized humans as a reference point
our brains just assume that their
dimensions are similar to our own in a
highly
hostile world with ice giants dragons
the size of jet liners and a literal
army of the Dead it's really not that
far-fetched that humans might not be the
dimensions that we think they are if
everything scales up in Westeros except
for the measurements that we're
explicitly given then it becomes clear
how everything in this world is working
Westeros feel so small not because it's
a small continent but because everything
in that continent is so big it's like
Rick and Morty's tiny planet
it explains troop movements which could
theoretically move at 40 miles a day
under normal circumstances and could
move at full pace at 48 miles every five
hours Jaime traveling 60 miles a day is
now a much more leisurely ride and he
could even pick up the pace a little
without seriously straining himself or
his horse
the Ravens could even move significantly
faster delivering the orders to the
troops faster and delivering the message
of success faster so no matter who you
are even if you're Shaquille O'Neal and
yes Shaq I know you're watching waiting
desperately for the day that I do that
Shazam theory you are quite a bit
shorter than Tyrion Lannister the dwarf
Peter Dinklage at four foot five inches
would be inflated to eight foot ten
inches a full foot and one inch taller
than the tallest NBA player and just one
inch shy of the tallest man in history
ha and you thought that the mountain was
just a nickname little did you know it's
because he's literally the size of a
mountain so the next time you watch an
episode know that to literally make this
world function we're looking at a very
different set of proportions than we've
thought this whole time but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and winter
is coming and you know what else is more
reality breaking theories slash the
throat of that subscribe button faster
than a Stark at the red wedding and help
film theorists finally reach 5 million
subscribers strong we are so close and
we are coming for you honest trailers
you and your sexy epic movie voice if
you want more Game of Thrones well then
check out how jour is gonna save
Westeros before the end of the series
yeah sir friendzone himself squeeze the
button on your left so hard it's like
Oberon's eye sockets and I'll see you
next week for even more death get ready